allez j'ouvre notre second débat débat
de société avec cette question
mettez-vous sous le sapin des cadeaux de
seconde main près d'un Français sur
trois langages 28% pour être précis
inflation et engagement écologique sont
les deux modèles moteurs d'un mouvement
qui grandit entre les sites de
e-commerce et des boutiques spécialisés
le marché du jouet notamment en tamsa
révolution démonstration avec ce
reportage de Cécile siksu en Normandie à
Bréal
Charline est institutrice en CM2 cette
année elle a eu un budget de 80 euros
pour fêter Noël avec sa classe et a
décidé de faire ses emplettes dans ce
magasin de jouets de seconde main tenu
par l'association aux jouets bonjour
j'ai vu un petit un petit bateau là en
vitrine là qui pourrait
m'intéresser mais en fait c'est pour ma
classe je cherche je suis enseignante
dans sa besace un bateau des jeux
d'échec et de construction pour la somme
de 18 euros 18 euros quand on voit tout
ce qu'il y a de qualité ça ce jeu là là
de 9 ça doit valoir je sais pas 30 30 35
euros je pense une solution économique
mais pas seulement elle souhaite
transmettre des valeurs à ses élèves
c'est un souci écologique un jeu en
moyenne
la durée de vie d'un jeu c'était sept
mois donc c'est quand même pas beaucoup
alors
je me suis dit il y a plein de jeux qui
restent dans les placards qui sont pas
utilisés donc ben c'est l'occasion de
réutiliser de donner une seconde vie à
ces jeux des personnes comme Charline
Flavie la gérante du magasin on voit de
plus en plus les habitants des environs
ou les touristes de passage n'hésite
plus à faire des cadeaux qui ont déjà eu
une première vie on a déjà le bouche à
oreille qui fonctionne beaucoup des
personnes qui reviennent régulièrement
des habitués et on voit vraiment
l'évolution tous les ans on a de plus en
plus de personnes qui qui passent le
seuil de la porte avant arrivé sur les
étals du magasin les jouets sont
reconditionnés à quelques kilomètres
dans cette entrepôt Laurent l'un des
salariés de l'association s'occupent de
récupérer les dons soit c'est des
particuliers qui viennent donc ici nous
amener les jouets soit c'est moi qui
vais les collecter dans différents
endroits donc ça peut être une
recyclerie donc à Granville le club de
foot ça peut être aussi des partenaires
on aimerions ouvrir des personnages avec
des barres associatifs cette année
l'association a sauvé plus de quatre
tonnes de jouets ils sont ensuite
vérifiés par des bénévoles
ceux qui sont incomplets comme celui là
par exemple je vais le mettre sur
l'étagère à compléter et on espère avoir
un prochain arrivage de Don avec le même
jeu une fois remis en état au compléter
le jouet peut être vendu à partir du
moment où un objet est collecté c'est
déjà plus un déchet donc c'est remise en
circuit de des différents jouets et
qu'on peut sauver un jouet en lui
redonne une seconde vie et ça ne suffit
à dire que on est dans une bonne
dynamique une bonne dynamique pour
toucher plus de gens l'association s'est
lancée l'an dernier à la vente sur
internet via des sites de seconde main
on met essentiellement des jouets plutôt
rares et précieux qui peuvent intéresser
des collectionneurs on a un camion
vintage on a des
un avion Fisher-Price qui est très
recherché également pour le moment seuls
les jouets rares sont mis sur le web
mais l'an prochain l'association espère
bien développer son offre
voilà et pour animer ce débat j'ai
trouvé un collègue encore plus
expérimenté que moi
[Rires]
bonsoir à tous Sandra va bien bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes la présente du
creedoc Camille Gréco bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes secrétaire général de la
Fédération de la mode circulaire et
cofondatrice de l'entreprise crush on
pierre Galliot bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi chef du service consommation
responsable de l'ADEME l'Agence de la
transition écologique en étant duplex
avec Adrien Valentin qui est le
co-fondateur de petite marelles
entreprises dont vous parlerez dans un
instant bonsoir à vous et Emily
évidemment est resté à mes côtés
spécialiste en communication politique
sans voix est-ce que ce Noël 2022 alors
je suis pas sûr que ce soit un cadeau de
seconde main celui-là mais bon c'est pas
très grave est-ce que ça peut être le
celui de la seconde main des cadeaux
d'occasion alors globalement la première
préoccupation en ce moment c'est
vraiment les questions de pouvoir
d'achat donc on a cette foyer sur 10 qui
nous disent qu'ils vont réduire leurs
dépenses et surtout c'est les questions
économiques en fait qui entrent en ligne
de compte donc aller chercher des
marques distributeurs des promotions etc
mais on a quand même un tiers de la
population qui qui est vraiment
préoccupé par les questions écologiques
et qui commence un petit peu à revoir
ces modes de d'organisation des fêtes de
fin d'année soit en essayant d'acheter
d'occasion donc on a 45% des Français
qui disent qu'ils ont l'intention
d'acheter d'occasion bon est-ce qu'ils
passeront à l'acte
on peut dire qu'il y a quand même un
rapport à l'occasion qui commence à
évoluer c'est à dire qu'auparavant et
notamment chez les anciennes générations
seul le 9 en fait était un vrai cadeau
qui comptait qui montrait qu’on faisait
attention à l'autre aujourd'hui
notamment chez les nouvelles générations
on a une valorisation de l'occasion à la
fois pour des questions écologiques mais
aussi pour des questions de singularité
on va aller offrir la petite chose qui
est un peu originale donc il y a un
rapport qui est en train de se
transformer par rapport aux objets
d'occasion
jamais qui a mis Greco si on parle des
vêtements on s'achète de plus en plus de
vêtements de seconde main mais pour en
faire un cadeau c'est une autre démarche
vous voyez ce que je veux dire est-ce
que ça marche aussi pour les cadeaux
parce que cette définition effectivement
déjà de prix d'écologie et puis de style
c'est à dire que on est vraiment sûr
d'avoir un cadeau unique quand on offre
un vêtement de seconde main et donc
aujourd'hui on le ressent il y a une
énorme augmentation de la consommation
de seconde main en termes de vêtements
et là lié au fait de Noël c'est à dire
que en général le la consommation de
seconde main explose et ça passe par les
vêtements et c'est en ligne et en
physique aussi donc on peut toucher tout
type de générations en ligne ce sera les
générations plus jeunes qui vont faire
des cadeaux potentiellement à leurs
parents pour les convertir et en
physique ce sera un peu plus des gens
qui ont pas forcément l'habitude d'aller
en friperie ou d'acheter de la seconde
un premier chiffre dans ce débat on va
en voir plusieurs évidemment offrir un
jouet d'occasion au lieu d'un jouet neuf
permet d'économiser
un kilos de CO2 c'est dans un rapport de
l'ADEME sur les impacts environnementaux
des fêtes de fin d'année petite
curiosité parce que c'est forcément une
moyenne comment vous arrivez à calculer
ce chiffre alors ce qui est important
c'est de rappeler que pour un objet que
ce soit un jouet un objet électronique
mobile ou textile le principal impact
environnemental il est lié à la phase de
fabrication et donc allonger la durée de
vie à travers le emploi la réparation ça
déplace la fabrication d'un nouveau
produit et donc on évite des
consommations de ressources de matières
premières et des émissions de gaz FSR et
après les hypothèses on a fait sont
complexe mais l'objectif c'est de se
dire que si on allonge la durée de vie
d'un an deux ans trois ans on va amortir
l'impact carbone de la fabrication et
donc on va être gagnant sur ce volet là
et c'est important de noter parce qu'on
sortir une étude sur les impacts
environnementaux notamment Noël
l'alimentation et transport les cadeaux
apparaissent comme les principaux
émetteurs au plus de la moitié et
lorsqu'on demande aux Français qui sont
prêts à faire comme effort
on sent qu'il y a effectivement les
mentalités qui changent et les grandes
enseignes se jettent beaucoup sur la
seconde main et cherchent à offrir une
offre secondaire en parallèle de leur
offre premièrement qui est leur métier
historique et donc on les accompagne
dans la création de cette offre de
seconde main à la fois pour aller
proposer la bonne offre à leur à leurs
clients la bonne offre aussi tarifaire à
leurs clients et puis les sourcés en jeu
de seconde main parce que c'est
aujourd'hui pas évident de
s'approvisionner en tout cas de
s'approvisionner avec les jeux qu'on
veut sur de la seconde main directement
il y a un autre démarche très bien merci
je reviens vers vous tout à l'heure
pierre Galliot il y a un autre chiffre
que vous allez pouvoir nous donner le
nombre de jouets là je reste sur les
jouets qui sont jetés chaque année en
France et assez vertigineux alors on a
un chiffre selon le cadeau notamment
pour les fêtes de Noël à peu près 300
millions c'est une estimation dont 12
millions qui sont considérés comme
inutiles qui correspondent pas aux
enjeux la personne qui le reçoit il y a
un million qui sont immédiatement jetés
forcément lorsqu'on a des cent mille
tonnes de jouets jetés chaque année en
France recyclé voilà alors après dans le
meilleur des cas alors ça peut être
employé revendu redonner ça peut être
évidemment recyclé dans le pire des cas
parce que ça reste un produit souvent
neuf qui n'est pas utilisé qui est
maintenant jeté donc le recyclage ne
résout pas le problème environnemental
il faut toujours avoir l'idée moi
j'insiste là-dessus que ce soit sur les
jouets les textiles ou autres c'est que
l'occasion en intérêt si c'est couplé à
une démarche comme le sobriété parce que
si c'est pour accumuler des biens
d'occasion et renouveler trop
fréquemment on retourne à la spirale
négative avec un effet retard par
rapport au rajouter ça puisque
finalement ça coûte moins cher donc on
va peut-être acheter un peu moins de
meuf mais si c'est pour acheter trois
produits dont on va pas beaucoup servir
donc il faut se dire je sobriété c'est
pas ce privé c'est juste toujours
revenir la question fondamentale qui est
celle du besoin j'ai réellement besoin
est-ce que je peux est-ce que j'ai pas
déjà chez moi ce qui arrive souvent pour
les vêtements par ailleurs est-ce que je
pourrais pas trouver notamment en
soutenant l'économie sociale et
solidaire pour pouvoir aussi créer des
emplois d'insertion et finalement de
l'emploi local alors cet en dont on
parle autour des jouets pour pour
démarrer ce débat il est bien identifié
par le gouvernement avec la secrétaire
d'État chargée de l'écologie Bérengère
Couillard qui sera lundi prochain elle
va visiter une enseigne spécialisée elle
va rappeler que des bornes de collecte
vont devenir obligatoire dans les
magasins de jouets à partir du de ce
premier janvier alors il y a certaines
anciennes qu'on en quelque sorte
devancer l'appel depuis 6 mois qui ne
jouait test dans un magasin près de
Valence on est dans la Drôme les clients
dont ils peuvent ramener rapporter leur
leur vieux jouets repartir avec un bon
d'achat en écoute le directeur du pôle
client et magasin
[Musique]
donc le but c'est de vraiment faire en
sorte que les produits issus de la
consommation de la production circulaire
soit aussi accessible que les produits
issus de premièrement et donc le but
c'est d'avoir une TVA réduite pour avoir
un prix réduit et donc inciter le
consommateur à consommer plus de
produits durables donc TVA 5,5%.
exactement ça pourrait être intéressant
c'est que ces vertueux c'est à dire que
au début on imagine ça comme une
contrainte de recycler tout ça et là
tout d'un coup ça devient un business on
essaie de favoriser enfin il y a des
idées comme ça de baisser la TVA ça
devient un véritable business de
revendre du recyclé mais aussi de
recycler soi-même et si on élargit même
au BTP au bâtiment et travaux publics il
y a tout un business qui est en train de
se faire sur je récupère du plastique et
j'en fais autre chose et je deviens un
acteur économique et je deviens un
acteur qui existait pas avant donc il y
a vraiment des choses qui sont très
positif alors qu'avant c'était vécu
comme une véritable contrainte
uniquement Sandra voit bien si on rentre
dans le détail vous l'avez un peu évoqué
tout à l'heure mais sur voilà là on est
voilà 10 jours de Noël donc il y a pas
mal de téléspectateurs qui qui vont
terminer de faire leurs cadeaux le
premier le premier
levier ou la première motivation d'un
achat de seconde main ça reste le
porte-monnaie on est bien d'accord alors
avant le langagement alors ça dépend des
catégories d'âge en fait donc en général
de toutes les manières c'est un petit
peu
fallacieux d'opposer économie écologique
puisqu'en fait on voit bien que par
exemple dans le cas de l'achat
d'occasion on achète à la fois moins
cher et c'est un petit peu mieux pour la
planète donc
la première la première motivation c'est
souvent les motivations économiques on
veut faire attention à voilà à son
porte-monnaie mais après
là de ce mois de décembre pour 75% des
Français offrir un cadeau d'occasion et
un moyen de faire des économies c'est ce
qui arrive en premier l'écologie c'est
un peu en dessous c'est pour 67% des
Français
comme comme raison mais après ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que dans toutes ces
pratiques qui sont en d'évoluer on
rentre souvent par des biais économiques
et après on peut finalement trouver
d'autres bénéfices des bénéfices à la
fois moraux en disant bah je fais
quelque chose de bien pour la planète
également finalement se rendre compte
qu'on peut avoir des choses qui peuvent
être intéressantes c'est possible créer
du lien social il y a tout un tas de
vous parler tout à l'heure de nouvelles
filières il y a tout un tas de nouveaux
lieux qui se sont créés des recycleries
des lieux où en fait il va y avoir un
peu d'échanges aussi on va réparer on va
recycler donc il y a finalement au
départ souvent des motivations
économiques mais qui peuvent ensuite
dériver ou en tout cas aller vers des
d'autres types de motivation
que la France est championne du monde et
c'est une bonne chose des filières
repent des filières responsabilités
élargi les producteurs point fondamental
parce que ça prouve que le metteur sur
le marché se débarrasse pas d'un produit
une fois vendu il est responsable du
produit une fois qu'il est dans le
circuit et donc maintenant il doit
financer la filière de recyclage en
effet c'est exactement ça devait
financer la filière de recyclage de
récupération et de valorisation
sauf que maintenant il y a des objectifs
dès qu'on conception des produits
fabriqués des produits à moindre impact
lorsqu'ils sont neufs des objectifs de
réemploi en volume et donc ça ça change
la donne de manière obligatoire
maintenant il va falloir mettre en place
ce qu'on appelle les collègues
préservantes faire en sorte que les
acteurs du secteur marchand mais aussi
les acteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire d'un forum emploi qui a été
développé dédié uniquement à ces acteurs
là pour pouvoir faire en sorte que
l'écosystème met en place les boucles
d'économie circulaire les boucles
locales pour à la fois capter ces flux
les valoriser et pourquoi pas évidemment
on espère créer de l'emploi local le cas
quand même les précédentes lois aget et
notamment ont vraiment fait en sorte que
l'allongement à la durée du produit soit
un enjeu anti-gaspi pour une économie
circulaire et je rappelle l'idée c'est
de sortir de l'économie linéaire
produire consommer jeter une question
Adrien Valentin qui a peut-être sur les
ce qui marche le mieux en location ou en
seconde main en ce moment parmi les les
styles de jeux
les jeux de société pour toute la
famille ça reste un des produits qui
partent très bien chez nous que ça soit
la location en seconde main on a les
trottinettes aussi notamment les
trottinettes évolutives qui suivent bien
justement la courbe d'éveil des enfants
et puis les conteuses les conteuses à
histoire qui marche qui marche très bien
et de aussi à Noël bon bah voilà ça peut
peut-être donner des idées de cadeaux à
celles et ceux qui nous regardent bon il
y a les jouets il y a les cadeaux mais
il y a aussi beaucoup d'autres gestes
possibles je pense que Tam traduit doit
être juste derrière le le rideau magique
de de science public
rebons soit ah oui très jolie c'est vous
vous êtes mis dans l'ambiance j'aime
beaucoup c'est très très joli ça vous
intéresse parfaitement bien donc la
question c'était comment passer à Noël
et correspondable oui voilà en dehors
des jouets de seconde main il y a
d'autres pistes qui sont données
d'ailleurs par l'ADEME dans son rapport
sur les impacts environnementaux des
fêtes de fin d'année puis aussi il
existe un guide pour passer à un Noël
écolo que l'on voit là à l'antenne donc
il y a beaucoup d'actions que l'on peut
mener pour cela par exemple sur les
cadeaux il y a rien de mieux que le Noël
canadien qu'on appelle aussi le secret
de Santa alors qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
quand on tire au sort le nom d'un membre
de sa famille ou de ses proches à qui
vous devez offrir un cadeau plutôt que
dans l'offrir à tout le monde et bien
l'impact est énorme à sa baisse de -34
kg d'émission de CO2 ça permet aussi
d'éviter bien sûr la course aux jouets
de personnaliser un peu plus son cadeau
et puis pour ceux qui n'y sont pas prêts
vous pouvez déjà aussi offrir un cadeau
de moi c'est toujours ça de gagner pour
la planète et puis vaut mieux offrir un
livre qu'un smartphone ça aussi ça
réduit beaucoup votre impact alors
est-ce qu'on peut cuisiner différemment
oui on peut par exemple cuisiner un
repas de Noël végétarien c'est un impact
absolument énorme exemple vous pouvez
remplacer le foie gras par le faux gras
composé de pois chiches de champignons
d'huile de coco et de plein d'épices
j'ai trouvé des tonnes de recettes sur
internet alors bien sûr c'est plus un
trompe l'oeil qu'un trompe papillon
n'espérez pas trop non plus vous tenez
vraiment à vos habitudes vous pouvez
aussi tenter le repas de Noël bas
carbone vous remplacez le foie gras par
du saumon fumé la bûche pâtissière part
de la bûche glacée et rien que ça ça
fait baisser de 23 kg vos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et puis vous pouvez
aussi réduire tout simplement le
gaspillage alimentaire en faire moins
pour réduire l'impact climatique du
dîner de Noël ça paraît une évidence
l'important sachez que 8 Français sur 10
reconnaît cuisiner des plats en quantité
excessive pour Noël donc il y a
d'énormes marges de Manage auxquels de
ces idées les Français sont-ils les plus
réceptifs ça assez drôle parce que dans
l'étude de la dame on découvre par
exemple que les Français sont prêts à
réduire le nombre de cadeaux des enfants
mais beaucoup moins ceux des adultes
allaient savoir pourquoi alors
certainement parce que l'on gate
beaucoup trop à nos bêtes blondes ou
brune alors également au niveau de la
cuisine c'est oui pour cuisiner locale
pour cuisiner deux saisons à Noël c'est
oui pour cuisiner dans des quantités
raisonnables mais en revanche pour les
Français c'est non pour limiter le
recours à la viande et aux poissons en
ce jour de fête donc passé au Noël
végétarien pour ceux qui n'ont pas du
tout cette habitude alimentaire je pense
que c'est vraiment pas envisageable pour
l'instant pour eux et puis sur la
décoration aussi les Français sont prêts
à faire des efforts ils se disent prêt à
limiter l'usage des décorations
lumineuses ils sont prêts à réutiliser
le sapin artificiel ils sont prêts à le
replanter si les naturels ou encore à
réutiliser les déclarations comme moi
parce que ça fait une boucle d'oreille
de toute beauté et c'est toutefois
sachez que c'est un poste d'impact assez
modeste ça représente seulement autour
de 2 kg d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre par personne
en revanche il y a un poste un poste qui
est très important celui des transports
en se déplace très souvent à Noël pour
rejoindre ses proches et massivement on
se déplace en voiture et malheureusement
trop peu en train donc voilà pour Noël
demandez à ce qui vous aiment de prendre
le train merci beaucoup Tam traduit
franchement ça vous va merveilleusement
bien cette boucle d'oreille j'adore
Sandra va bien est-ce que alors il y a
un engagement environnemental dont on
parle quand même dans ce débat c'est un
je pense un mouvement quand même de fond
dans dans une grande partie de l'opinion
on peut on peut dire ça et puis il y a
Noël cette période particulière est-ce
que c'est forcément le moment où les
Français parlent le plus d'écologie ou
envie de s'engager en la matière la
réponse est dans la question
effectivement
la période de Noël c'est un peu un
espèce de parenthèse qu'on espère offrir
d'ailleurs il y a aussi toute une partie
de la population qui ne pour qui c'est
en fait presque une source de sacrifice
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont mettre ils vont
se priver par ailleurs pour pouvoir
préserver ce moment un petit peu de
exceptionnel alors tout à l'heure il y
avait des recommandations surprendre le
train etc après il faut quand même
rappeler qu'on est quand même dans une
période où l'inflation est très
importante et les prix de l'énergie et
les prix dans les magasins donc les
mouvements écologiques sont possibles
quand il y a convergence parler de
l'occasion sur le train c'est pas
toujours simple non plus parce que les
prix sont aussi assez important donc
voilà donc à la fois il y a cette envie
de se préserver et puis il y a aussi des
contraintes économiques qui font que
c'est pas toujours non plus très simple
de d'aller vers des conduites
écologiques Camille Greco je l'ai dit on
vous présentant vous êtes également la
cofondatrice de crushion c'est un c'est
quoi c'est un rassemblement de friperies
professionnels c'est ça comment ça
marche de la mode circulaire c'est à
dire qu'on travaille avec plus de 2000
friperies professionnels à qui on m'a
donné des des comment dire des
possibilités de vente des canaux en
ligne ou en physique c'est à dire qu'on
va les connecter avec des grands
retailers comme Gary Lafayette ou
Citadium qui ont des cibles de
consommateurs qui n'ont pas forcément
l'habitude de d'aller en friperie
une capacité de ce professionnaliser
encore plus et on fluidifie le marché de
la seconde main c'est intéressant parce
que ce mot friperie il est assez ringard
il y a encore quelques années c'est
l'image est en train de changer on dit
boutique vintage c'est mieux c'est vrai
que le mot friperie a encore pas mal de
préjugés qui lui collent à la peau mais
c'est vrai que en fait il y a de plus en
plus de consommateurs qui se tournent
vers le vintage parce que c'est une
nécessité aujourd'hui et on peut plus
acheter dans les boutiques de fast
fashion sans savoir ce qui se passe
derrière et donc il y avait vraiment de
plus en plus une conscience écologique
qui se tourne et le vintage est vraiment
une porte d'entrée vers la mode durable
oui avec avec un paradoxe quand même
dans la dans la toute jeune génération
dans une autre émission mais voilà il y
a des je vais pas citer la marque mais
il y a une marque chinoise qui cartonne
auprès des ados parce que c'est très
très peu cher et là on est vraiment dans
la caricature de la mode jetable et
c'est pour ça que ça va être hyper
important de sensibiliser le
consommateur et qui est une vraie
information derrière le vêtement et d'où
ça provient d'ailleurs enfin pour
rebondir sur vos propos on va que le
discours revient en force l'alimentaire
et non alimentaire pour notamment des
raisons économiques mais pas que ce qui
est aussi important de de dire c'est
qu'ils vont les messages
moins cadeaux sobriété s'applique à ceux
qui peuvent se le permettre ça a été dit
la sororité subit c'est pas la sobriété
c'est la précarité donc faut bien faire
attention encore une fois ce que les
messages ils sont jamais générés qui
dépendent de population on l'a dit c'est
un moment de fête c'est un moment de
plaisir aussi et donc il faut bien faire
attention à cela point complémentaire on
le disait tout à l'heure
ce qui est fondamental on voit bien ce
sont bien les normes sociales et
représentations
la fête Noël c'est forcément l'opulence
c'est une représentation sociale et et
il faut beaucoup de place
elle assumée parce que nous enquêtes
montre le gaspillage alimentaire c'est
95 % des Français le rejet etc c'est
moins grave pendant les fêtes parce que
voilà c'est le moment de plaisir et on
peut offrir ce qu'on souhaite oui tout
noter les spectateurs du Sud ils vont
pas renoncer à l'heure je sais plus
c'est 14 décès parce que c'est la
tradition quoi voilà c'est ça
il y avait une superstition j'ai pas osé
13 non mais la question et c'est vrai
pour les fêtes comme pour plein d'autres
sujets c'est un peu les dogmes mais la
représentation qu'on a de ce que c'est
qu'une vie réussie ça va sur
l'automobile ou les fêtes c'est comment
aussi on peut évidemment s'en déroger la
tradition et ce qui fait notre culture
est-ce qu'on est comment on peut aussi
par rapport aux conditions auxquelles on
vit changement climatique autorisation
de certaines populations comment on fait
pour les faire évoluer et bien ce que
déjà tout le monde puisse en profiter et
qu'on puisse répondre réseaux sociaux et
climatiques alors vous avez parlé de
sobriété Émilie zappalski justement on
va on va parler de de la communication
du gouvernement sobriété et décroissance
sobriété décroissant celle-là parce que
vous l'avez dit un réchauffement
climatique il y a eu garantie il y a la
guerre en Ukraine avec la crise
énergétique les difficultés aussi d'une
éclairbe et tout ça ça a poussé le
gouvernement à se lancer dans la
sobriété et c'est vrai que c'était pas
forcément des thèmes qui lui était très
familier il y a peu Emmanuel Macron
d'ailleurs c'était moqué des amis et du
modèle de la lampe à huile elle a
changement de ton en octobre on nous
présente un plan de sobriété on nous
explique comment éteindre nos appareils
électroniques comment baisser nos
radiateurs avec la température on s'en
souvient tous du 19 degré maximum pour
tout ça pour réduire nos consommations
d'énergie alors est-ce que c'est pour
autant le retour au modèle à biche mais
non forcément alors oui à ces appels au
gestes et aux bons réflexes sur comment
réduire nos consommations d'énergie mais
le message est il est bien clair il
s'agit juste de passer l'hiver sans
coupure d'électricité ça on l'a bien
compris mais surtout pas de lancer le
pays dans la décroissance un projet qui
est complètement aux antipodes des
promesses du Président Emmanuel Macron
Emmanuel Macron c'est le chantre de la
croissance économique et il veut pas
faire de lien avec la décroissance pour
lui la sobriété c'est juste plus
d'efficacité énergétique 100 ans il l'a
dit même le 6 octobre juste avant la
présentation du plan de sobriété je
reprends ces mots l'énergie consove
c'est la moins chère et ça veut pas dire
produire moins ou aller vers une
économie de la décroissance pas du tout
ça veut juste dire gagner en efficacité
il y a une multiplication aussi des
déclarations dans les discours des
ministres voilà exactement Elisabeth
borne Agnès panière une haché le jour
même de du plan de sobriété Elizabeth
borne qui dit la sobriété énergétique ce
n'est pas produire moins et faire le
choix de la décroissance il y a vraiment
ces mots Agnès panière une haché dit
elle la sobriété ce n'est pas s'arrêter
de vivre elle parlait notamment des
décorations de Noël à la baisse ou pas
justement dans les rues alors avec ce
plan de sobriété on est surtout dans la
gestion de l'urgence sur les mesures
conjoncturelles une vision en quelque
sorte un peu court thermiste de la
transition écologique pourtant et on l'a
dit vous vos témoignages va vous en
parlent les Français semblent être prêts
en fait à aller plus loin en tout cas
certains d'entre eux et en fonction de
leurs moyens et inscrire la sobriété
dans leur mode de vie ils ont déjà
diminué leur consommation d'énergie si
j'ai bien compris si pour ça voire même
un peu plus ces derniers temps et poussé
par l'inflation c'est vrai il mise
davantage sur le marché du recyclé sur
le vintage si on veut le dire
correctement et de la seconde main même
pour les cadeaux de Noël et même les
grandes enseignes et vous l'avez dit 6
mètres en développant des gammes qui
sont spécifiques sur le recycler H&M
close the loop ça veut dire boucler la
boucle ou Carrefour et encore d'autres
même les entreprises de luxe s'y mettent
une façon finalement de continuer à
consommer mais à partir de mode de
production et avec des produits qui sont
plus respectueux de l'environnement une
sorte de produits mieux pour consommer
mieux une autre idée de la croissance en
phase avec les enjeux de sobriété
transition écologique en fait c'est tout
simplement en même temps mais c'est
bizarre parce que Emmanuel Macron qui
est lui-même l'inventeur du concept mais
on dirait qu'il a du mal à jongler avec
ceux en même temps qui est poussé par
les consommateurs actuellement merci
Émilie mais Camille Gréco je crois qu'il
y a 150 entreprises c'est ça qui est qui
sont 156 membres de cette fédération de
la mode circulaire et si elle est grande
est-ce qu'elle est géants de de luxe ils
sont là on a kering on a printemps le
but c'est vraiment de représenter toutes
les entreprises qui de sont de près ou
de loin qui ont une activité dans la
circularité et le but c'est vraiment de
pouvoir faire en sorte qu'elle se
rencontre autour d'une table et qu'on
trouve des solutions ensemble parce
qu'en fait la circularité c'est un rêve
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas aller une
circularité parfaite ça touche tous les
phases du cycle de vie du vêtement de
l'éco-conception jusqu'à la distribution
la consommation aussi et puis ensuite le
recyclage donc il y a énormément de
points sur lequel on doit agir et donc
ça prendra du temps mais il faut il faut
pierre Galliot il y a un autre effet
positif sur dont on n'a pas encore parlé
je crois c'est sur l'emploi la
relocalisation ou la pérennisation de
l'emploi local mais c'est très important
avec cette idée de d'économie circulaire
ou de exactement il faut comme ça que
l'immense majorité des biens
manufacturés sont importés et creuses la
balance commerciale de la France voilà
donc alors que lorsqu'on réussit à avoir
un système économique qui permet à la
fois on l'espère de fabriquer en France
mais faire en sorte qu'on a des produits
justement qui sont réparables qui sont
réemployables avec les filières qui sont
locales et qui permet justement de
limiter les déplacements on a un emploi
non délocalisable alors on a déjà
l'insertion à travers l'économie sociale
et solidaire le Réseau des Ressourceries
Emmaüs les compagnons mais bien entendu
mais on a un potentiel d'emploi qui est
extrêmement important et donc on peut à
la fois conjuguer cette économie cette
cet impact sur l'environnement qui est
non positif et le développement des
territoires c'est aussi ça qui est
important c'est qu'on peut Rev réaliser
recréer du contact
au sein des collectivités notamment
Sandra voyant il y a une autre dimension
que je trouve intéressante il y a pas
mal de de ces entreprises qui sont dans
l'univers de la de la seconde main qui
qui travaille avec des ESAT qui font qui
fournissent finalement du travail et des
personnes en situation de handicap
est-ce que dans l'acte d'achat de d'une
partie des Français ça devient un
argument
ou pas d'ailleurs est-ce que vous l'avez
identifié
que qu'effectivement les critères
sociaux parce que le local en fait
rassemble l'un de préoccupations à la
fois les préoccupations d'emplois les
préoccupations de souveraineté et
préoccupations écologiques et des
préoccupations économiques donc tout ça
fait qu'en fait il y a beaucoup de gens
qui se retrouvent dans cette idée
d'aller acheter local sur l'achat avec
des préoccupations sociales c'est pas
aujourd'hui dominant dans notre dans
notre société il y a un peu aussi une
une mise à distance finalement de ces
impacts sociaux on en parlait tout à
l'heure avec toutes les productions qui
peuvent être faites dans des pays où les
droits du travail sont pas les mêmes
qu'en France on essaye un petit peu à
distance on n'a pas tellement envie de
le voir d'une certaine manière les
déchets aussi par exemple les déchets
des vêtements sont envoyés dans d'autres
pays on ne les voit pas en fait donc
voilà qui en souffre particulièrement
donc c'est des montagnes de vêtements
qui polluent exactement donc tout ça ça
fait tout un système qui fait que on en
a pas assez
que je le redis mais il y a toujours
cette notion du prix qui est quand même
prédominante Adrien Valentin voulait
intervenir sur cette question
je voulais juste préciser sur le sur la
partie ESAT et l'inclusion nous on
travaille depuis le début avec avec un
esad justement pour tout ce qui
reconditionnement des jouets et
effectivement c'est peut-être pas la
l'argument majeur dans l'acte de
d'abonnement chez nous de nos clients
mais on a beaucoup de messages de nos
clients pour savoir comment on travaille
quels sont nos valeurs etc donc je pense
quand même que de plus en plus les
consommateurs regardent le produit mais
regarde aussi les valeurs qui sont qui
sont véhiculées par la marque et je
pense que c'est important aussi de
pouvoir mettre en avant ces initiatives
et de montrer que les marques produisent
bien ou travail la seconde main et puis
aussi ont des valeurs
sociales et d'inclusion donc je pense
que ça c'est quand même un argument à
mettre en avant auprès des auprès des
consommateurs Émilie zafalski oui j'ai
l'impression qu'on a eu des labels bio
des labels commerces équitables qui
étaient très lisibles mais surtout ces
aspects-là on n'a pas encore quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre de la
visibilité de ces paramètres dont vous
parlez c'est à dire est-ce que je fais
travailler des esad des personnes
handicapées est-ce que je suis dans
l'inclusion est-ce que que je recycle
mes déchets et il faudrait probablement
rendre plus lisible ou le coup carbone
aussi est-ce que j'achète un produit qui
a un coût carbone réduit ou pas et ça je
pense qu'il y a l'égalité salariale
et c'est pas encore visible il y a pas
de la belle où il y a pas d'éléments qui
nous dit sur l'étiquette bah j'achète ça
dans le produit vous avez parfaitement
raison alors ce qu'on appelle
l'information environnementale et
sociale déjà porte
ultra majoritairement sur les produits
neufs donc on a des labels
environnementaux quels qu'ils soient on
a l'étiquette énergique et de carbone
l'indice de réparabilité voilà tout ça
c'est pour les produits neufs qui
peuvent inventer le consommateur déjà
l'information sociale existe quasiment
pas ou alors comment font les personnes
ils vont sur le lieu de l'achat voilà
dans des Ressourceries ils vont demander
ils vont directement au plus près sur
les boucles locales qu'on évoquait tout
à l'heure il est vrai qu'un véritable
progrès à faire dans typiquement le
reconditionné qui est un intérêt
également véritable fort il y a la belle
qui va arriver d'ici un an qui permettra
de dire le parcours de reconditionnement
et qui permet de mettre en avant un
produit à
mais là-dessus clairement on ne rentre
pas assez le consommateur et à la fois
on doit parler à l'offre parce que c'est
l'offre qui va pouvoir informer sur les
impacts environnementaux sociaux et le
consommateur qui peut orienter
évidemment ses choix alors puisque on
est toujours à essayer aussi de vous
soufflez des idées de cadeaux tiens si
vous voulez vraiment faire des économies
de CO2 par exemple il y a une bonne idée
c'est d'offrir un smartphone
reconditionné puisque au lieu d'un
smartphone neuf là aussi c'est le
rapport de l'ADEME ça permet
d'économiser 49 kg de d'émission de CO2
donc c'est vraiment un impact on va dire
positif qui est très important Adrien
Valentin je reviens vers vous parce que
est-ce que tu as les consoles de jeux ça
fait partie des produits qui sont
demandés ou alors est-ce qu'on est
victime de ce syndrome de la nouveauté
dans dans le domaine de la tech et des
consoles de jeux
ouais alors nous c'est quelque chose qui
nous est qui nous est pas demandé alors
c'est quelque chose qu'on serait pas en
mesure de faire de toute façon et qu'on
doit pas aujourd'hui mais effectivement
je pense qu'il y a il y a un effet
vraiment mode nouveauté on attend les
nouvelles sorties qui est très
importante à part peut-être sur quelques
nostalgie de certains jeux ou console
vintage mais aujourd'hui on a très peu
de demandes sur ces sur ces produits là
il y a ceux qui sont nostalgiques de
pong et c'est le premier jeu vidéo de de
tennis qui ressemble à rien on était
super content de de jouer avec Sandra
webian
on est quand même j'allais dire
configurer mais c'est vrai que sur tout
ce qui est tout ce qui est tech tout ce
qui est
téléphonie smartphone tablette etc
console tout le monde achète du neuf
quoi oui et puis à tout le monde mais
pas longtemps c'est-à-dire que par
exemple un smartphone en général c'est
garder maximum deux ans un Français sur
deux le garde deux ans donc c'est quand
même pas beaucoup il y en a beaucoup qui
dorment aussi dans les dans le tiroirs
les anciens qui sont pas recyclés qui
sont pas on pourrait pourtant valoriser
et c'est vrai que mon appareil de la
jeune génération elle est aussi
ambivalente c'est à dire que d'un côté
il y a effectivement une attention à
l'environnement sur un certain nombre de
choses manger moins de viande acheter
d'occasion et sur le numérique il y a
quand même une consommation qui est
assez importante et on voit pas bien
comment ça diminuerait en fait en tout
cas à court terme à moi qui est vraiment
une pénible de ressources
j'ai un pc reconditionné qui marche
super bien aucun souci reconditionné
chez les jeunes il y a quand même plus
de recours au conditionnel chez les
jeunes voilà mais par contre la
fréquence d'achat et le nombre
d'équipements qu'on a et les usages le
temps d'usage est plus important et
puisqu'on est sur les générations
je reviens à Noël et au cadeau est-ce
que quand même il y a il y a une
question de génération c'est à dire
est-ce que est-ce que les parents les
grands-parents hésitent beaucoup plus
que les jeunes à offrir un cadeau de
seconde main la réponse elle est un peu
dans la question aussi oui très
clairement quoi neuf qui est différent
suivant les générations un rapport aussi
à la possession c'est à dire que chez
les jeunes ce qui va plus dominer c'est
le fait d'avoir de l'usage de pouvoir
profiter d'un service mais finalement
est-ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de
posséder l'objet alors que chez des
générations un peu plus anciennes on va
beaucoup accumuler en fait donc on va
avoir des intérieurs qui sont bien
remplis en général et on se débarrasse
assez peu finalement de des objets dont
on n'a pas d'usage Camille Rico quand on
l'a évoqué on parle d'éco-conception des
des produits donc c'est faire en sorte
que que par exemple le petit télé
électroménager soit facilement réparable
on peut citer ce que fait une marque
comme Seb et les produits maintenant
sont garantis 15 ans donc ça voilà ça
veut dire quoi l'éco-conception quand on
parle de vêtements c'est le c'est
sourcer les matériaux d'origine c'est ça
c'est mieux produire intégrer plus de
circularité dans les matières intégrer
des matières plus durables comme le lin
au lieu du coton par exemple faire en
sorte qu'il y ait plus de moins de dos
que le coton c'est ça d'accord
donc voilà pouvoir s'assurer que le
vêtement est éco-conçu et qu'ensuite il
dure plus longtemps ça c'est surtout ça
qui est important c'est que en fait un
vêtement qui n'est pas éco-construit à
la base ne durera pas donc au-delà de du
recyclage etc il faut que ce soit bien
conçu pour ensuite qu'on puisse moins
consommer
j'en profite tiens parce qu'on va faire
passer un message vous parliez de ces
téléphones portables qui dorment dans
notre tiroir c'est alors on va expliquer
c'est le concept de mineur exactement
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire et qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait en faire de cette de ces
téléphones smartphone vous avez près de
50 métaux matériaux différents avec une
haute valeur ajoutée et quand vous savez
pour quelques grammes parfois de de
métaux rares il faut des tonnes de
matière mobilisées pour les la phase
d'extraction c'est une phase extrêmement
impactante l'aspect énergétique mais
aussi biodiversité et donc laisser
dormir parce que ça peut toujours
resservir bien sûr des est-ce qu'on
croit c'est comme rarement le cas c'est
finalement perdre une valeur certes
marchande mais surtout un impact
environnemental lié encore une fois à
l'extraction de matière neuve alors
qu'on pourrait tout simplement à la fois
récupérer ces matières là et également
pourquoi pas créer de l'emploi
localement
je vais faire mes courses de Noël demain
et puis je me rends compte que j'ai
trois smartphones qui dorment dans mon
tiroir je peux les apporter dans une
enseigne ils sont prises notamment des
points téléphoniques qui peuvent
complètement récupérer ses appareils là
il y a des encore une fois des filières
REP ou les apports sont les points
d'apports sont prévus ça va des piles
textiles d'ailleurs d'un sujet il y a
des progrès évidemment à faire mais
c'est toute une filière qui se met en
marche encore une fois pour mettre le
réemploi d'abord parce que c'est quand
même ça l'impact majoritaire et en fin
de vie leur recyclage allez je vais
terminer il nous reste quelques minutes
avec la pression sociale des des cadeaux
alors c'est déjà difficile de trouver le
bon mais si en plus on prend le risque
de vexer en offrant une occasion je vous
dis pas pourquoi je dis ça parce que
c'est ce que ressentent 37% des Français
ce même sondage Opinionway pour 37% les
Français offrir un cadeau d'occasion est
un faux pas voilà le terme qui les
emploie alors enfin que leur a et puis
alors il se sentiment de honte même
alors je vous propose deux autres
chiffres 42% des Français auraient honte
d'acheter des cadeaux d'occasion aux
enfants et 45% des Français d'acheter
des cadeaux d'occasion aux adultes là
c'est le rapport de l'ADEM pierre
Galliot des Français qui sont pourtant
ultra majoritaires à dire qu'on produit
trop de déchets donc là on est on touche
aussi une des contradictions dans un des
paradoxes la plupart des enquêtes
environnementales il est toujours plus
valorisant de dire qu'on se préoccupe de
la question que dire l'inverse et on a
toujours une dichotomie mais ça c'est la
vie entre le déclaratif et réaliser on a
tous contradictions en voiture dans
Paris tout le monde peut se faire
attraper ces questions là la vraie
question c'est l'accompagnement au
changement on a fait une opération il y
a un peu plus d'un an qui s'appelait aux
échanger qui visait justement à changer
reprendre en moi sa consommation on se
rend compte de ce qu'on a de ce qu'on
doit faire plusieurs journées
d'accompagnement d'ailleurs c'est
souvent les les femmes du foyer qui
prenaient des choses en main petite rem
beaucoup plus de la pression déjà
quotidienne
en tout cas pour beaucoup de monde et ce
qui était impressionnant j'ai un chiffre
notamment sur les chaussures en moyenne
les adultes du foyer avec deux fois plus
de chaussures que ce qu'ils imaginaient
et trois fois plus que son réellement
besoin donc il y a toujours une
représentation entre le besoin ce qu'on
a est-ce qu'on souhaiterait avoir qui
est important donc le changement c'est
pas facile marque Twain disait que pour
changer une habitude il faut pas la
passer par la fenêtre il faut descendre
l'escalier marche ça marche et donc ce
qu'il faut aussi c'est de faire à pair
apprendre changer petit à petit pour que
ça devienne vraiment un réflexe et pas
une violence évidemment de changer ces
normes et sa représentation cette
pression sociale des des cadeaux se
rendra hautement quand comment elle
s'exprime c'est vrai que vous parliez
des femmes c'est souvent les femmes en
fait qui sont dans cette charge
émotionnelle il faut choisir le bon
cadeau pour la bonne personne donc c'est
pas seulement du temps c'est aussi se
préoccuper d'autrui également qui porte
aussi les charges écologiques donc cette
pression en fait elle porte beaucoup
beaucoup sur les sur les femmes qui sont
encore aujourd'hui on va dire les
principales en charge des questions de
liens social des questions de relation à
l'autre et effectivement ne pas apporter
le bon le bon cadeau c'est d'une
certaine manière
risquée à un impair risqué de se fâcher
avec avec autrui donc il y a aussi
beaucoup d'enjeux autour des normes
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un bon cadeau
quel est le bon montant au contraire il
y a ceux qui se disent ah bah non je
vais on va dire c'est la honte tu
m'offres comme tout le monde là ou au
contraire celui qui veut dire bah super
c'est exactement ce que j'attendais je
voulais pas que tu achète un enjeux
autour de Noël des enjeux aussi de
représentation de soi c'est à dire
est-ce que finalement je suis une bonne
mère un bon père est-ce que je suis un
bon hôte etc donc il y a beaucoup de
pression autour de Noël un peu moins
autour d'une nouvelle an il y a une 30%
de la population qui fait pas le nouvel
an alors que sur Noël on est à 96 % des
Français qui font Noël donc oui la
pression elle est là résolution oui bon
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on va vous
souhaiter par avance de de bonnes fêtes
de bonnes dernières courses de Noël
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce
débat ici et en duplex évidemment et je
vous laisse méditer sur le le double
sens du mot cadeau en indien ça se dit
pardon pour la prononciation sabir chez
nous qui ça signifie à la fois le don et
le poison
intéressant ça rejoint ce que vous nous
disiez donc ne nous laissons pas
empoisonner par par les courses de Noël
et par le choix des cadeaux merci à
toutes et à tous de votre fidélité je
voudrais remercier toutes les équipes de
Public Sénat celles qui sont en régie
qui danse et qui chante très bien ils
l'ont trouvé hier soir au karaoké on
vous souhaite à tous de belles fêtes je
vous remercie ici aussi l'équipe de sens
public évidemment Elsa Dario là haut de
Fauvelle Alice Bardot Louis Heinrich et
notre directrice de l'information
Perrine Tarneaud je vous dis on sera là
à l'antenne pendant toutes les fêtes
avec les meilleurs moments de de
l'émission et on se retrouve en janvier
salut à toutes et à tous
[Musique]